so as we continue to await results in
many states we wonder
how many mail-in ballots are out there
in various states
we are getting news that there could be
hundreds of thousands of
missing ballots missing ballots the u.s
postal service had a deadline of
yesterday
to sweep their mail processing
facilities
in more than a dozen states for missing
election ballots because of reports that
ballots were just
sitting around they could be hundreds of
thousands of total ballots when you look
at some of the margins in the states
still being counted
you quickly realize hundreds of
thousands of that ballots could make a
huge difference
u.s district court judge emmett sullivan
in dc
ordered the sweep tuesday morning when
the postal service said
that its delivery performance was down
and they couldn't say whether more than
300
000 ballots received had been delivered
well then you've got to see if the
ballots are still at the postal center
the sweep was supposed to happen in 12
specific districts
including in arizona florida
georgia pennsylvania texas wisconsin i
think you understand the importance of
this
the judge gave the agency until 3 30 pm
to finish the task
at 4 30 the postal service said sorry
we couldn't do it would have disrupted
our election day
activities they said they would continue
a daily review process
to find and deliver smaller amounts of
ballots
we don't know how many ballots are
currently missing the window
is closing very quickly the deadline for
mail-in ballots
depends on what state you were in
but it was tuesday night in a number of
different states there are reports of
undelivered ballots that have started
cropping up even from the past weekend
miami-dade county
listen i'm not saying anything in
particular but miami-dade county
was expected to be more pro-biden than
the numbers
bore out and miami-dade county is one of
the places where mail-in ballots have
allegedly gone undelivered
i'm just giving you the information this
is a red alert
in pennsylvania alone one of every two
ballots rejected in the last election
were because of a missed deadline
and the margin was only 44 000 votes by
which donald trump defeated hillary
clinton
this has to be taken uh extraordinarily
seriously
this is just one example relating to
potentially 300 000 ballots that we know
of
look at the margins this is a
potentially election
changing number of ballots these ballots
could decide a state or two
and these are exactly the ballots
that donald trump told us at 2 am last
night
he is going to go all the way up to the
supreme court if he needs to
in order to stop the counting of these
ballots and donald trump wasting no time
this morning
in starting the conspiracy theories
let's talk about that next privacy.com
is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you five dollars just for using
their free service at privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn
from your checking account but your real
card number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month you can set spending
limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman